[Music]
now by the end of this episode you're
going to know the name for each one of
these individual candles you can find
them on pretty much any Candlestick
chart like we have on this one right
here which we're going to use as an
example but let's go ahead and step back
for a moment and dissect just an initial
candle just to make sure we're all on
the same page so I'm going to go ahead
and erase this this is from a project
that we were working on uh yesterday for
students at Warrior trading and we're
going to start by drawing a simple
candle now candlesticks were created in
the 1700s by a Japanese rice Futures
Trader and they have been became very
popular in Japan and then made their way
uh to the West uh many years later this
is a typical candle and it communicates
four pieces of information the four
pieces of information include the open
the
close the high and the low now all of
these candles here on the back also
include those four pieces of information
but the difference in the shape is based
on the differences between between the
open the close the high and the low so
the shape of course communicates
sentiment ultimately a Candlestick is
reflecting the price action that
occurred during a period of time and it
communicates the battle that is going on
between the buyers and the sellers as
the candle finally closes at the end of
that session the end of that trading
period we have a shape that communicates
who was really in control was it the
buyers or was it the sellers so so let's
talk about how this works now a
Candlestick represents a period of time
now in in the older days these candles
were primarily daily charts so a daily
chart would mean this candle represented
all of the price action that occurred
within one day of trading activity so
the market opened down here this is the
open right this is the bottom of the
candle and the price uh obviously
declined because it hit a low down here
so at some point it declined
and we don't know exactly how it deined
but what we know is of these four pieces
of information is enough to create the
candle and it gives us enough
information about the sentiment the low
is created and then at some point it
comes all the way up to here to create a
high which is H and then it pulls back
and closes right here so more or less we
know that this is what happened during
that day of time now it's possible of
course that the price opened and we went
all the way to the high came all the way
to the low and then came back up to
close here so we don't know exactly what
happened intraday but regardless of the
way this candle was created this is the
way it closed so this is the final shape
and this becomes the candle on the
record for that day of time now I'm an
active day trader and so although I use
daily charts to help me understand the
the big picture context if I like the
daily chart then I zoom zoom in to
shorter time frames to help me myself
find an entry now my average trades are
only about 5 minutes long so I actually
spend more time studying technical
analysis analyzing potential patterns
and trying to find entries than I
actually spend trading which only
reinforces why this is so important for
you to learn okay so for me I'm not
using daily charts I'm using uh one
minute charts one minute charts
primarily which means each of these
candles is just 1 minute 60 seconds of
time all right 60 seconds of time right
here and so all of this can happen very
fast now on a stock that has just ipoed
or on a stock that has breaking news a
lot can happen within a minute as you
will certainly see as we dive into some
of these charts okay so this is the
anatomy of how a candle is created this
is of course a green candle a red candle
still communicates these same four
pieces of information except it opens
high and it closes at the bottom so the
candle then is red in color so the only
thing that's switched is the open and
the close price because the close was
lower than the open and this is why we
do need to differentiate green and red
candles because the open and the close
are flipped between these two candles so
for some people that are color blind
they'll have uh red candles that are
solid filled with color and then they'll
have the green candles be Hollow and
that's a fine way to do it uh but for
anyone else who's has no problem then
red and green become the colors that you
use and this is uh this is very common
so now let's start to talk about what
some of these different Candlestick
shapes mean all right so I'm going to do
this um again on this side I'm going to
erase this here and we're going to start
over with a clean whiteboard and we're
going to draw a candle where the price
this is the open so the price opens here
and the price is going to decline a fair
bit it's going to come all the way back
up we move up very quickly to here and
then we pull back and we close right
about here so we've got the open the
close the high and the low so if we
plotted this out and this is how you
would actually create these charts in
the old days before charts were created
for you you would be able to draw
something that looked kind of like this
now this is a standard Candlestick shape
and it has a long upper shape Shadow or
an upper candle wick right here and it
has a lower candle wick right here this
is a bullish candle because the low uh
is is wait sorry the uh the close and
the open are far enough apart that it
shows that the buyers pushed the stock
up however anytime we have a larger
upper candle wick this shows selling
pressure sellers pushed the price back
down and it wasn't able to close at the
very top so a more bullish candle would
be one that doesn't have an upper candle
wick at all it just simply squeezed all
the way up to this high and then closed
right there right naturally that would
be a much stronger candle even if it
still had this lower candle wick because
this lower candle wick or this lower
Shadow while it shows that the price did
decline here it shows that the buyers
bought it back up which is bullish so in
total this bottom candle wick and lower
Shadow is bullish and an upper candle
wick or an upper Shadow is beish we
would prefer to see of course a stock
open squeeze straight up and close but
that doesn't happen uh much of the time
when we look at these this is an actual
Candlestick chart and we zoom in here
you'll see that really there there are a
small handful of candles that are have
that shape this is one of them right
here so this candle is solid green
opened at the bottom closed at the
top and as I look at this chart right
now I think that may be the only candle
that is like that except for this one
right here but it's so small it doesn't
communicate nearly as much sentiment as
this huge green one creates so it's much
more common when we're trading and when
we're analyzing charts that we will
expect to see upper candle wicks or
lower candle wicks so it's important to
note that upper candle wicks are bearish
and uh because they're pushing the price
back down and these lower candle wicks
are bullish pushing the price back
up so the first candle right here is
called a long body candle it has a it
has a long body as the name suggests
this is true with both red and green
candles they're both longbody candles so
body refers to the actual body of the
candle
so if we have a candle here the body is
this section right here and these are
the candle wicks so if you were actually
holding a candle this one would have a
candle wick at both ends this is the
body of the candle in the middle and
it's also sometimes called the real body
and these are the upper and the lower
candle wicks and some people call them
Shadows I don't really prefer to call
them Shadows because that's straying
away from the concept that the are
candles candles don't have shadows but
uh candles do have candle wicks so I I
I'm from this point on in the episode
we'll just refer to these as candle
wicks so upper candle wick and lower
candle wick and this is the body so a
longbody candle has a very long body now
if we go back over here we could draw a
um oh just for the sake of adding one I
could draw a small body candle or a
short body candle right here oops this
one has to be in red so a short body
candle is just a very small candle right
here so these are these would be short
and these would be long naturally which
one do you think communicates more
strength weakness or sentiment in
general bigger candles communicate that
there's a lot more emotion in the market
if we look back on this chart there's a
lot of emotion in this candle and
there's probably a lot of emotion in
this candle and as active Traders we
want to trade volatility and volatility
comes from emotions now we'll talk in a
few minutes about how I sort of decide
the right type of financial instrument
to try to perform technical analysis on
but we'll save that for a moment okay so
our first two candles are uh small and
longbody candles so I'll just abbreviate
SML small and longbody candles okay so
these both communicate well the longer
ones communicate uh much more strong
sentiment and the smaller ones uh less
so now let's talk about the next
Candlestick shape okay so we're going to
back this up here and we're going to
create a new
candle and based on what you have just
learned about candle wicks what does
this candle communicate is it is it
communicating more strength or more
weakness well it has that long lower
candle wick and we know that that is
bullish it's bullish on the one hand
it's not as bullish as a longbody candle
so we have to accept that however it's
more bullish than the inverse which
would be like this if you had to choose
between these two candles you would
always prefer this one because the lower
candle wick shows that although the
price declined it was pushed back up so
again if we kind of do the anatomy of
how this candle was created the price
opened the price began a decline to hit
a low it then came all the way back up
to close here so it showed an incredible
amount of strength to recover that loss
so this was the open the low the high
and the close are at the same price
anytime the high and the low the high
and the closer at the same price on a
green candle that's communicating even
more strength we closed at the high
sellers weren't even able to push it
down going into that Final close which
on some candles um it just communicates
an incredible amount of strength so this
is a candle right here that does
communicate strength this has a long
lower candle wick right here and it has
a small upper body now I will tell you
that this is called uh in certain
instances this candle is called a
hammer and the reason it's called a
hammer is that when you have the price
that's been declining like this a lot of
weakness let's say these are all
longbody candles these are all we'll
just make it kind of small but these are
all longbody candles the price has been
declining and then down here we suddenly
get this shape right there what we know
about this candle wick is that that
candle wick creates a bullish sentiment
the buyers bought it back up and of
course we know in this context the first
green candle could be significant
this almost looks like a hammer or a
mallet and it's called a hammer because
the thought is that it's hammering out
the base so if we sort of Drew the
hammer you know someone's swinging it
like this someone's swinging it right
they're swinging the hammer and this is
the base the low of the pullback right
here the low of this dip is the new base
now this is a candle that indicates
bullish sentiment is coming in and what
we look for is for the next candle to
confirm that by going green and moving
higher so in this particular instance
this candle right here is giving a big
signal it's giving us a Buy Signal and a
lot of beginner Traders will miss it
completely they'll see the C the candles
that are red they'll think it's too weak
I'm not going to buy it and then by the
time it starts bouncing up here they're
thinking oh maybe I should get in like
up here up here but the smarter traders
who have done their technical analysis
and have learned how to read this signal
are buying right here here the second
this green candle makes a new high we
have a multi Candlestick pattern now
we're going to talk about a number of
multi- Candlestick patterns in a moment
as we go through this class but I want
to talk about the first one right here
uh the first one is uh called candle
over
candle so it looks like this it's just
two candles next to each other however
this green candle has broken over the
high of the previous red candle and for
that reason it's called a candle over
candle pattern so right here we have
candle over candle now this is a green
candle and then this is a green candle
that broke over which is just fine it's
still candle over candle whether it's
red or green so it's first candle making
a new high so the candle over candle
pattern this is a two candle pattern one
candle which is the trigger candle and
then the second candle is the one that
makes the new highve so in this context
right here this is called a hammer now I
will tell you that it has another name
that's a bit more ominous but the these
names do communicate a bit of a story so
the hammer is communicating that the
base is being hammered out however if we
see this candle up here and it's
red this is called a hanging man
here's the problem with this
candle it opened high and it closed
lower it is true that we have this
bullish candle wick that it dipped down
and came back up but it's showing for
the first time ever in this context some
degree of weakness as we said we would
prefer to see longbody candles long body
long body long body so we finally see it
like this well that starts to be a
little bit concerning so that candle
right up here and we'll make the body
just a little bit
bigger this is our hanging man candle
hanging man we'll just write it like
that um and this can be a hanging man as
well hanging man as long as the body is
big enough that's still the head so this
starts to communicate a bit of um
indecision however uh this candle right
here is called a gravestone
so if we flip
this like
this that is called a gravestone and
that is an even worse candle to see in
this context because you've got all
these candles coming up and then you
have this big bullet uh sorry bearish
upper candle wick and this small body
right here now when we have a candle
that opens and closes at more or less
the same price so opens it squeezes up
it gets pushed all the way down and then
closes here this is called a uh oops a
do dogee there we go so a dogee candle
is a candle that opens and closes at
more or less the same price a gravestone
dogee has this tall upper Shadow a
dragonfly dogee has a long tail down
here like a dragonfly
does and a long-legged dogee is just a
sort of long range here and this is your
standard dogee it's more of a more of a
cross just like this all of these
candles communicate the same thing in a
sense what do they communicate let's
just think about this for a second the
price opens it goes up it goes down and
then it closes the communication that
we're getting here is that there's a lot
of indecision in the market buyers and
sellers are in a battle and right now
nobody's winning however let's think
about this a little bit deeper so if we
have the price that has just made an
incredible rally to the
upside what do we have we have momentum
we have strong sentiment and then all of
a sudden at the top of that rally we see
indecision what do you think is likely
to happen this is often a warning sign
for a reversal or a correction now now
at the end of the day we don't know from
this candle right here where the price
is going to come all the way back down
like this and this would be called a
true reversal or if the price is just
going to correct like this but what we
do know is that if we're in this
position and we bought it sentiment is
Shifting and it's a good idea to lock up
some profit and either get out of the
entire position before we get that
candle under candle pullback which which
is that two Candlestick pattern going
the to the downside uh but either lock
up the entire position or scale down to
a very small size that you can afford to
hold during this type of pullback now
when we're looking at a Candlestick
chart as you'll see on on this
Candlestick chart and as we'll um as
we'll look at on a couple others uh that
we have right back here we often will
see that the price will sort of move in
these uh waves so you don't always
necessarily need to exit the entire
position just because you're on a
correction you can still hold a piece of
it but it's just a reminder that we're
getting a pullback now this right here
actually shows a small dragonfly dogee
you see how this has the flat body at
the top and then the slightly longer
tail it's not a very long tail but it is
a small dragonfly dogee and you could
almost almost call that a gravestone
dogee it's not perfect because the body
is a little bigger and the tail uh or
the upside candle wick is not huge but
it's close to that and then this
certainly is a long-legged dogee so
notice though that you have these
topping tails that Mark the high
bottoming tails that Mark the low
topping tails that Mark the high and
whenever I'm going through um these
these examples we'll often note these
large topping Tails right large topping
tail noting reversal bottom bottoming
tail here noting a reversal from a pull
back to a move back up so once you start
to learn to recognize the shape of these
candles and ask yourself what is this
candle telling me that's the beginning
of you starting to pick up on those
subtle signals in the market and these
are buy and sell signals you may not see
them yet but they're there so once you
start to train your eye to recognize
them you're going to start seeing them
on a lot of charts and this is the
process of build building that
confidence now in order to convert this
general knowledge that I'm sharing with
you right now into an actual skill that
can make you money what do you think you
need to do you need to practice a lot
all right so let's get back to the
Whiteboard though all right so we've now
talked about our hanging man candles and
we've talked about our uh gravestone
dogee uh down here gravestone
dogee now I want to talk about golly I'm
having a temp dra on that all right
that's fine so we got the gravestone
dogee um and we have our Hammer candle
right here this is a
hammer and we've got the green candle
there now there was another candle that
I haven't shown you yet uh which is very
similar to this but it's just a little
bit different so the gravestone dogee is
typically going to look more or less
like this but remember that if it's like
this or it's like this
you know it you have to kind of keep in
mind that there are no two Candlestick
charts that are identical and so while
we have the textbook definition of a
gravestone dogee that opens and closes
at the same price right here what
happens if it closes two cents lower
what if it's 4 cents lower right does it
really change the sentiment not
significantly and so if you call it a
gravestone dogee that's fine if it
starts to get a little bigger like
this a little bigger like this you know
now it's starting to take a little bit
of a different shape we call this candle
here a shooting star why do you think we
call it a shooting
star it's because this candle when it
occurs at the top of a move like this
usually is an indicator the price is
going to come back down however what we
need in order to confirm that this
indicator is in fact correct is that
candle under candle pattern so the next
candle will
open and it needs to break the low of
this candle right here it needs to break
the close so when that happens the
moment that happens we now have a
shortterm a correction that is beginning
and then if the next candle breaks the
low yet again and the next candle yet
again yet again yet again then we're on
a straight pullback however if in this
area let's just say for instance we have
this small body candle right here and a
little bit like that this starts to look
a little bit like a hammer right we're
starting to get a little bit of that
hammer shape which means this is the
base right so we we draw the hammer kind
of sideways it's hammering out this base
right
here so that means this could be our
potential new support
level these candlesticks and the shapes
that occur help us Define areas of
support or resistance you're going to
have these topping tails up around
resistance you're going to have these
bottoming Tails down around support
areas of support have demand see the
bulls the bulls bought the stock back up
so this is
support slash demand there are buyers
down here and up here we have
resistance slash Supply so up here we
have people that are willing to
sell now we came up up here we pulled
back this right here what's this pattern
called when we have two candles like
this this is the candle over candle
pattern as this green candle moves back
up so a very common trade for me would
be to be a buyer right around here not
uh right right at this price the moment
this green candle crosses the high of
this red candle and my Max loss would be
down here this would be my Max loss
right here now we're going to talk about
this pattern a little bit more in a
moment we've got our um our Hammer we've
got our hangman we have right here our
shooting
star shooting star and again these can
be both red and green some people are a
little bit sticklers about this um
shooting star I really think that the
sentiment is pretty clear and it's only
stronger in one way or the other
depending on the color so if this is red
it's an even stronger confirmation even
in this existing candle that the price
is already reversing quickly
than if it was green so if if this was a
green candle it's like okay well you
know obviously we we certainly still
have the same weakness same sentiment
but it did close a little higher so
let's see what happens it's possible
that you could have this as a momentary
kind of battle and then you have a red
candle but it doesn't make a new low it
just kind of goes right there and then
next thing you know you've got another
green candle and we're rallying back up
and we're pushing against this
resistance level and seeing whether or
not we can test it so that's not
uncommon ultimately I'm not going to
want to exit the position if I'm into
the long side until we have that candle
under candle formation and then I'm not
going to want to get back into the buy
side until we have that candle over
candle formation and so for what it's
worth if I was if I would have been
entering this um you know let's just say
this had squeezed up like this the the
place I would have been a buyer would
have been uh right in here that's the
candle over candle right down there so
that would have been our entry this
would have been Max loss based on these
two candlesticks here it's just a two
Candlestick pattern and then profit
would have been uh exiting right here
first candle to go down now this is
starting to get into a little bit of
strategy on a multi Candlestick pattern
this is the first multi Candlestick
pattern but it's worth noting that this
multi Candlestick pattern right here is
not going to be significant to a candle
over candle formation if the price for
instance is going sideways so like in
this area right here I'm just going to
zoom into this
area in this area right here seeing
candle over candle is not as significant
right in here for instance it's
meaningless down here we do have a
little bit of selloff and then we have a
candle over candle and that carries more
meaning that's fine but then we go back
into an area that's more less sideways
but like right in here right in here
these don't lead to significantly bigger
moves to the upside because here's the
thing the stock is already going
sideways it's already
indecisive so similarly let's write down
a couple of
rules so rule number one you remember I
talked about
dois being candles of indecision dois
only important and I'll just
important when trending so this is like
uh stock market hieroglyphs so do are
only important when the stock is
trending in other words they're not
important when the stock is going
sideways because what do dois
communicate they communicate in decision
if the stock is going sideways it's
already indecisive so this doesn't tell
us anything more than we already know
but it's important to know this so dois
are only important when they occur
specifically near the top of a move or
near the bottom of a move these are the
areas where they can indicate a possible
revers
number
two
hammers shooting
stars and hanging
men which is also a dogee variation
again only important only important
during strong consolid strong trending
up or down those are the only times that
they're important when you see a hammer
or a shooting star but the price is
going sideways like sort of in this area
here it doesn't carry the same weight so
when are the times that candlesticks are
going to be respected the
most it's when they are giving us the
clue of a change in Direction so we're
using candlesticks to help us predict
when the price is going to change from
going up to going down even as a trend
based Trader and I trade with the trend
I'm an easy go-lucky person I just like
go with the flow right so I'm trading
with the trend the price is moving up I
want to be trading it as it moves up too
however what I know uh let's see where's
where should I draw this what I know
we'll just draw it small is that price
never goes straight up like that it
always goes up in waves and so to help
me manage my risk it's better if I can
buy on one of these momentary pullbacks
so that means the area I'm going to be
watching closely are these areas right
here because we're getting a reversal
at the top and then a little reversal
here at this pivot so we sort of pivot
at the top for a little correction and
then we pivot here for the move back up
pivot here pivot here pivot here pivot
here now this is the area where I'm
really focusing once the price starts to
kind of drift sideways once again not
interested so we really only try to
perform technical analysis on a stock
Forex pair cryptocurrency curency
whatever you're trading that is trending
that is moving that has potentially tens
of thousands or millions of other people
watching it at the same time that's when
the signals are going to be received by
the most people and you're therefore
going to see the most um the most
extreme reaction to these signals and an
extreme reaction to a reversal signal is
going to be a big
move so uh one other candle so again
this can be a hammer but it's only a
hammer when it occurs at the bottom of a
move it's a more of a hanging man when
it occurs at the top uh this is called a
spinning
top spinning top right here same here
spinning top so a spinning top um just
like a top it's just again it
communicates indecision similar to a
dogee it does have a small real body
here but it's just not very big and this
is more or less a longbody candle but
just has um a little extra candle wick
on the top and the bottom so more or
less a strong sentiment candle but just
with a little bit of that extreme um
this we already talked about in the
context of a move up it's a shooting
star or potentially a gravestone dogee
depending on U depending on how big the
body
is okay and then uh the dragonfly dogee
and the standard dogee and the
long-legged dogee we already talked
about so separate sort of breakaway
reminder on the dois we've got the
long-legged dogee the standard dogee the
gravestone Stone uh dogee and the hammer
sorry the the gravestone dogee and the
dragonfly dogee right there those are
four standard dois okay so now let's
jump back in here and start to put the
pieces together on how these
candlesticks communicate more sentiment
and and and and really give us a
specific entry or an exit so right here
you can see very clearly we've got
something that's moving it's trending up
now what I can tell you about this
particular um security is that typically
what what I'm looking for is a catalyst
so if we jump back onto the Whiteboard
here part of my job with technical
analysis and especially as an educator
is to teach you that it's a myth to
think you need to have picture perfect
candlesticks because real life isn't
Picture Perfect it's not like textbooks
same with nature it's messy it's sloppy
it's just it's never quite the same so
you have to be able to use your own
critical thinking to look at a pattern
and understand in totality the message
that it's sending is it bullish is it
bearish are we having a battle here is
this the spot where we're going to see a
swing in price and so rather than trying
to find Picture Perfect patterns I want
you to focus in instead on making sure
you're trading the most obvious
Financial instrument because you know if
you if you see a pattern and you think
it's really picture perfect but nobody
else in the entire world sees it who's
going to be buying that
breakout nobody because nobody saw it
right if a tree falls in the forest and
you know no one's there to hear it fall
does it make a
noise nobody will ever know and that's
kind of the problem with these patterns
if there could be a perfect pattern but
nobody sees it so that's why stocks like
Tesla or the S&P 500 are so popular
because if there's a pattern no one will
miss it now one of the challenges with
trading those types of stocks is that
you're also competing against some of
the biggest and best hedge funds and
highfrequency trading algorithms in the
world these guys are so good and they've
Mak they made so much money they hire
phds in math to create these incredibly
complex algorithms
to predict the market but they only do
that on markets where they can put
millions and millions of dollars in and
take millions and millions of dollars
out so the type of markets that get very
thickly traded with these incredibly
Elite Traders are markets on large cap
stocks Nvidia Tesla Apple Google Netflix
these household names that you're
familiar with S&P 500 this is also true
with commod of these contracts it's true
with with currency payers because
they're just so popular so my Edge has
always come from Trading stocks that
have breaking news a stock that has
breaking news will bring a lot of retail
Traders off the sidelines in to trade it
because you see that there's a news
Catalyst that's moving at higher so on
the individual days when a large cap
stock has news okay I'll I'll cons I'd
consider it but more or less on any
given day what I'm trading is usually a
lower price stock that has some type of
breaking news that's a big deal for that
company and so if we look at this here
this is an example of a stock that went
from about $2.30 a share to $4.40 a
share so went up nearly 100% And it did
it and this is a f minute chart here so
it did it over the course of like an
hour and it did it naturally on breaking
news so this is the type of thing that
is going to create a lot of emotion and
there's millions of shares of volume so
people are buying it and selling it and
Rapid trading and the pullbacks are
respected the patterns are acknowledged
so many Traders are seeing it this is
where we start to get really clean and
clear price action okay so let's jump
onto the Whiteboard and kind of talk
about uh one of one of my favorite
patterns so one of my favorite patterns
here um begins typically with a news
catalyst so we're going to have breaking
news right down here
and let's just say it's at 8:00 a.m. all
right Eastern Standard Time not that
that really matters but I'm just going
to throw it out there now for those that
are curious you can trade the Market
opens the US Stock Market opens at 4:00
a.m. for pre-market trading that goes
till 9:30 a.m. and then um from 9:30
a.m. until 400 p.m. is regular session
and then 400 p.m. to uh 8800 p.m. is
after hours so most Brokers will allow
you to trade both pre
and after uh pre-market and after hours
in addition to regular hours right here
and so you may have to change your order
settings to enable uh premarket or after
hours trading but most most uh Brokers
will allow it the only thing to note is
that there are no stop orders pre-market
or after hours so that means when you're
trading you have to have uh ideally a
button that you've scripted to your
keyboard that will allow you to press it
and exit with a limit order so this is
difference between limit orders and
Market orders not to get into weeds here
but just I wanted to mention it okay so
nonetheless um I actually do a lot of my
trading at beginning starting at about
7:00 a.m. and I'm usually done most days
by 10: to 11:00 a.m. unless the Market's
really strong um and that just works
really well for my schedule and for what
it's worth if you're trading in Europe
you know you're sitting down here at 100
p.m. uh in in Europe and you could trade
until you know 5 5 6 p.m. if you're
trading in Japan you're sitting down at
8:00 p.m. 7: am. so 13 hours ahead
you're trading at 8:00 pm and you're
finishing at you know 10 p.m. 11: p.m.
so you've got Traders all across Europe
and Asia that trade the US market Hawaii
is a tough time zone I think they're at
um like 1 it' be like 1:00 a.m. but we
do have students at Warrior trading that
are in Hawaii and trade the US market
but the reason the US market is so
popular even among International traders
who could choose to trade their local
exchange is because of the combination
of volatility and liquidity because if
you're going to day trade you need to be
in markets where you can move in and out
with you know big enough size to make
your daily goal whatever that might be
my daily goal is $5,000 but I should say
as always my results are not typical and
there's no guarantee that you'll find a
similar result that's my disclaimer that
I always remind people of okay so news
is at uh 8 a. here on this particular
example and immediately instantaneously
the news comes out and the price
squeezes up this happens it's it just
happens like in an instant so the price
squeezes up right here and what we
typically have is news comes out instant
longbody candle longbody candle one
longbody candle two now the problem with
longbody candles is that you know you
can't really easily Buy in the middle of
one because it's going to be extended
relative to where it was before this
Catalyst came out before the news began
so typically what I do is I wait for
that correction now what are some of the
Poss possible correction candles that
could occur right
here okay so I'll just give you some
options of Correction candles possible
possible candles that indicated
correction we could have dois we could
have a standard dogee we could have a
long-legged dogee we could have the
gravestone dogee or we could have the
dragonfly dogee those are four different
does that could right here if they were
in this position right here could
indicate a possible reversal so I'll
just we're kind of filling in the blank
of what's going to happen inside this
candle um or so that's that's option
number one a dogee option number two we
could have a
um a shooting star right here and it
could be either uh red or
green okay so a shooting star we could
have a hanging
man so we'll do the hanging man here
like this and all of these are
indicating
um these of course are indicating a
decision these are indicating a very
high likelihood of a reversal because we
already have this bearish topping tail
this is a little bit more we've got to
wait to see because we have the the
bullish bottoming tail but the the body
closed here so this is the low of the
body so if we had this Candlestick shape
right here let's choose number three
number three well you know what I'll go
through what I would do in each case but
number three is the most most
complicated if we have a dogee right
here I would wait to take my entry until
we break the low of the dogee right
there so if I was going to go short I
would be shorting as soon as that level
breaks or if I was holding to the long
side I would sell as soon as that level
breaks right there and I would get out
okay so that's the spot right there
where I'd be exiting if this is a dogee
if this is a shooting
star same thing shooting star I would
getting out or uh taking a short
position the second this next candle
breaks the low of candle number one so
this a two Candlestick pattern that's
one this is two the second this candle
makes the new low candle under candle
I'm out of the trade now if we had a
hanging man
candle this one's a little bit trickier
because usually here's the problem we
want to be going uh getting out or going
short for candle under candle but it
closed way up here which means if this
candle goes red we wouldn't be shorting
until way down here that's already
forming kind of a longbody candle and
that may be basically the full extent of
the correction so in this particular
case I would consider a break of the low
of the candle's body right here to be my
indicator to get out so right here the
second it breaks the low that could be
an indicator to get out now this is a
little bit tricky because it's not
officially candle under candle until
you're way down here but if this is a
long candle wick I may not want to hold
that far down so that's going to be the
most complicated um of the three
potential choices that you have for for
reversal candles okay so let's say that
we got a dogee here and then the next
candle was a small body red candle and
I'm just going to switch to this pen
here for a moment so small body red
candle okay so we did a candle under
candle so I'm out of my position or in
this case because news just came out I
never even took a position yet I'm just
watching we get another small body
candle so this is candle in this pattern
candle number
three now I suppose in truth this is at
this point a five candle pattern because
it's not a pattern without these big
green candles these create the context
but we don't need to count the candles
in the pattern because it doesn't matter
how many are in it so what we know here
is that we have these three candles that
went up that squeezed higher let's go
ahead on this side and draw this a
little bit larger so you can see it more
clearly okay so we had the breaking news
we had candle number one we had candle
number two again don't don't need to
count it don't know why I'm counting it
again and then we have this candle here
that pull pulled back and another candle
here that pulled
back so now at this point we've seen the
move up we've seen the dogee that
indicated a reversal we've got a
pullback for the first candle a pullback
for the second candle now I'm starting
to think about first candle to make a
new high and a move back up my first
profit Target will be a move back to the
high of day which is up here right up in
this area but I'd like to see a move
even higher so where do I buy
I don't really want to buy just right
here because the price might just keep
trending lower now if this candle had a
bottoming tail here what does a
bottoming tail communicate buyers so
this is something that would be
desirable if we saw this bottoming tail
that would be desirable but regardless
of whether or not we see the bottoming
tail I'm going to wait for the first
candle that makes a new high so making a
new high is when the price of this
candle breaks the high over the previous
candle so we go from making a new low a
new low a new low relative to the
previous to now making a new high now
there are times where we will have a
candle um at the bottom like this where
it opens it dips down and it closes here
and it's green but I don't usually buy
this candle because we haven't yet made
a new high so I'm still a buyer on this
candle right here but I may be buying
almost the moment this candle opens
because remember if we close here
presumably we're going to open it more
or less the same price and now we're
going to be opening into that first
candle moving up so this is a time where
I'm going to be pretty quick to jump in
and it is bullish because we have that
bottoming tail right there and then
we're starting to Surge back up and this
is the setup that I
trade this is now a multi Candlestick
pattern and this Candlestick pattern has
two longbody candles
one standard dogee one small body red
candle one possible Hammer candle
hammering out a base giving us a little
bit of a reversal this in this context
would not be a hanging man because a
hanging man only occurs at the top of an
uptrend a shooting star only occurs at
the top of an uptrend a hammer occurs at
the bottom of a pullback so this is a
hammer even though it's the same
Candlestick shape the context is what
gives it the name CU at the bottom it's
bullish whereas at the top it's starting
to be a little not so great all right so
then I'm I'm entering down here this is
a place where I'd be a buyer right here
I would
buy this would be my Max
loss and let's say this is a ratio of
$100 approximately dollar amount so then
I want to be able to make approximately
200 so this is 100 plus 200 plus right
so that's what we would be looking for a
2:1 profit to loss ratio and getting out
up around this area now if you can do
this and trade with a 2: one profit to
loss ratio you only need to be right 33%
of the time in order to break even
that's just a statistical fact so if you
write 50% of time 60% of time 70% of
time well then you can be doing really
well so for those that are curious my
trading has been between 65 and 70% over
the last8 years which has been good and
I produced over $10 million of net
profit after fees and commissions I'll
say again my results are not typical but
they are verified they are audited you
can see that on my website if you're
curious and it is trading more or less
the variation of this strategy and
several others exclusively using
Candlestick charts to help me understand
my best entries and exits so this is a
standard multi Candlestick pattern that
we would typically call the bull flag so
bull
flag bull flag a few candles going up a
couple candles pulling back and then
first candle makes a new high now in
addition to the bull flag we have an
ABCD pattern so I'm going to teach you
the ABCD pattern here
ABCD now the ABCD pattern is a little
bit different um it's similar but what
happens on the ABCD pattern and we can
do this one as a um oops we'll do this
one here as a little gravestone
dogee and then we're going to pull back
and then we'll just say um we do a
little bottoming tail there and then we
move back up right
here but in this case you see how we
have this dogee up here so these topping
Tails they're really tough because it
shows that the price could not hold that
level so in this case we come back up to
this level but we don't go through new
highs we sell off again we dip back down
and this is now creating an ABCD pattern
a
b c and what do you think is d d is the
next leg up right here so what we look
for on an ABCD pattern is the price to
come back up and on the second attempt
it goes through the high so well wait a
second but this is just a bull flag
you're right this is a bull flag and I
would still take this trade but it
doesn't go all the way to the first
profit Target and so as soon as we have
a red candle that makes a new low candle
under candle I get out this is still
going to be a winning trade in this
particular instance because I'm in right
here and I'm out right here it's just a
small winner it pulls back again and
then what I know is that the more times
this resistance level is tested the more
likely it is to break so I can do one of
two things for an ABCD pattern I can get
back in right here at Point C which is
basically a bull flag pattern but the
second attempt I will do that as long as
there's enough room to get profit out if
it comes back to high a day this is the
high right in my hand at resistance so
as long as I can make a little bit of
money from right here to right here I'll
take the entry here if it's too close
together the word I won't be able to
make money if it just runs into
resistance I'll wait until it looks like
this level's going to break and then
I'll get in right here for the breakout
and my stop is at the low of the
pullback although that's a larger stop
what we know about this pattern is that
this longer period of
consolidation serves as coiling and
building strength for that final break
through that level and so we often see a
really big breakout off of the ABCD
pattern so I always teach people the
bull flag first because uh an ABCD
pattern includes a bull flag that
ultimately did not resolve all the way
to the upside and then it turns into
that ABCD pattern now there are also
times where we end up with what we call
a um ma uh pullback I'm just going to
abbreviate it here a moving average
pullback and in a moving average
pullback we have this sort of similar
one two big green candles whatever dogee
at the top it dips down a little bit
first candle make a new high squeezes
back up isn't able to break through
pulls back again comes back up one more
time can't break through pulls back
again you know kind of Dipping down and
basically at this point I'm going to
stop trading the first candles to make a
new high because we're just sort of
pulling back at this point typically
we're looking for support around a
moving average like the 9 EMA the nine
exponential period moving average this
is going to be on a a 1 minute or a 5
minute chart and then once it's tapped
this level this level creates support
and then that's when we're more likely
to finally break away but initially at
the very beginning of the move it may be
a bull flag it may be an ABCD pattern
and both of those fail but I'm still
going to keep watching it this is not a
picture perfect pattern when it goes
sideways for this long but the question
is is the stock that I'm trading and in
my case I'm trading stocks but in your
case you may be trading something else
and that's okay am I trading the right
thing am I trading something it's
obvious that everyone else is watching
because if you are you're going to see
better resolution than if you're trading
something that nobody is looking at
things that nobody look at the only
people buying and selling maybe is a
couple of mutual funds adjust a position
add a little sell a little but you don't
have retail traders that are buying into
it so when we think back about stocks
like um GameStop right when we had this
incredible move on GameStop that was
driven by so many retail Traders
watching technical analysis of course
understanding the power of short
interest and buying the pullbacks it
didn't go straight up even in the areas
where it made big moves it pulled back
and went higher pulled back and moved
higher and those are the areas where I
was training it I was buying those dips
and then looking for that squeeze to the
new level and then once we get that
candle under candle I was getting out
letting it pull back not knowing if it
was going to come all the way back down
or just pull back a little bit and then
get back in for that next leg up now if
you want to continue learning about
technical analysis and how to read
Candlestick charts I'm going to put a
link in the description where you can
download my 112 page PDF this is a
resource you can download you can print
it out and I encourage you to put those
uh printouts around your your trading
station and some of them are going to
look kind of like this because you want
to have these all around because your
job as a Trader is to begin to visualize
the pattern completed when we're trading
in real time we only see the beginning
part of the pattern we see the two
longbody candles the one dogee the one
red candle the second red candle and now
we have to visualize what's going to
happen next we use technical analysis to
help us get a inclination of what we
think is going to happen next But
ultimately it's about pattern
recognition and that pattern recognition
the more times you see it the more you
recognize it well it's going to build
confidence so I encourage you to
download that PDF I also encourage you
to practice trading the strategies that
you're learning from me in a safe
simulated trading environment because
look there's no business putting real
money into the market until you first
proven you can make money in a simulator
and I'll tell you guys the market will
be here for you it will wait for you I
mean it's not going to wait for you but
it'll be here for you and there will be
other opportunities so don't feel that
you should jump in with real money right
now before you're ready you do that and
you're going to lose money it took me
years to get to the point where I was
consistently profitable and it took me
many more years before I got to the
point where I made my first million
dollars trading it takes time but pay
your dues study up and hey you know what
if you enjoy this episode hit that
Thumbs Up And subscribe to the channel
for more episodes about trading strategy
just like this as I end this episode
I'll remind you as always that trading
is risky my results are not typical and
there's no guarantee you'll find success
as a Trader whether you trade with me or
you learn on your own so manage your
risk take it slow and I'll see you for
the next episode real soon